hello everyone welcome to our
presentation
uh we are delighted to welcome you uh to
our little project that we have been
working on for like the
you know last couple of months um so we
have for you here
today um a new technique that we have
developed
uh both of us and it's called ensemblex
so
it's like a recipe for all you all to
you know like
combine different neural networks in the
deep learning domain
and you know solve a lot of problems
with it and
what will we you know try to achieve
with this
uh well that's that's what the
presentation is for right
so let's let's let's dive into it now
okay so my name is deepam paul
um and i belong from the city of kolkata
in india
and i'm a final year undergraduate
student pursuing electronics and
telecommunication engineering
and my area of interest has been exactly
this medical imaging
and the deeper using deep learning
techniques and tools um
i've also worked at various labs in and
across the world and
um this is my first pi data global and
i'm really really really excited to be
here
and i i wish it if it was you know in
person but
well uh you know what we'll have to make
do with what we have
so yeah that's that's pretty much about
me and there's like a picture of my city
there
and a little you know minion there so
that's that's kind of where i belong
from now over to my uh co-presenter
uh thank you that was an a wonderful
introduction as well so greetings to
everybody
my name is and i'm from the city of love
now
in india now my city luck now is
famous for its lip smacking food its
culture is
history its history and its architecture
as well
and uh i am also an undergraduate
student in my final year
and pursuing the same uh electronics and
telecommunications and
you know my interest in deep learning
and
machine learning and artificial
intelligence is something that
was the reason behind people when me
crossing paths in the first place as
well
like one of the reasons or one of the
things that we connect on
together we've like worked on various uh
different projects as well
in the you know last couple of years and
everything so yeah
having said that i have also had the
privilege to
work at you know some different labs and
be a part of different conferences all
over the world
whereas this is my first pirate global
as well and i am also very excited to be
here and i really look forward to this
enriching experience
now over to you deepak
thank you so much um so we really
thought about you know if you
put a lot of thought into this so we
thought like before uh
you know deep diving into what we have
done it's it's it's very important to
you know pray homage or
tribute to all the advancements that
have been made
in this particular field of medical
imaging um
so now i think a lot of you you know are
already probably familiar with what it
is
but um i'm sure a lot of you in fact i
had this curiosity that this
probably is you know a new world thing
as in
you know since we have the you know like
uh privilege of having so much compute
in today's world so we might
just uh you know like have tools
available to us such as you know
different deep learning architectures
etc
uh therefore we we are able to you know
achieve so much with
medical imaging but actually that is not
true
it started out in the late 1800s and
it it's been there like throughout you
know a
entire century and it's still going on
uh so this just proves
you know like how how you know uh
progressive this field has been over the
years
and yeah it it does feel uh quite
gratifying in order to you know
contribute in the same uh
you know field that has had so many
scientists brilliant minds working
together
so let's move on so first uh
let's let's let's look at why you know
did we
actually you know want to solve this
problem i think this is one of the first
questions we should answer before
uh deep diving energy into the
presentation so
uh can we move on to the next slide
correct so it's very important uh so
when we stumbled across this problem so
so essentially when we started out we
were dealing with three data sets
one was of skin legends one was of
malaria
images uh cellular images and the third
one
was oct images so these
you know data sets have been previously
worked on by different authors
and uh you know they have work they've
used like multiple architectures as well
in order to validate their results and
classify whatever uh
you know the problem statement required
them to but what they did not
solve except for the accuracy part are
what were quite a few aspects actually
to name a few
to just give a brief will of course like
you know like tell you more about it in
detail
for example they did not take into
account about modern reliability
and that that does play a very important
role in you know areas such as these and
we will know
in the consequent slides about how and
exactly why it's important
but this is exactly where we stumbled
across the problem and we really thought
that you know combining different target
access together
actually could you know solve a lot of
problems than having just one
architecture
there and you know have it classified
over and over again
so if you can move to the next slide uh
so yeah now a very important uh context
of the problem
from you know where we come from
actually so
uh we'll talk about the problem of
variance so the problem of variance is
of course a very uh
you know important problem that that
that we you know set out to solve
um so as you all know that when we talk
about medical images
patients real-time patients every case
is
almost special you know like at least
different from the another
and to rely entirely on a algorithm
to solve your problem that algorithm has
to you know
live up to its standards i mean uh it
has to be that that's
that resilient enough in order to not
not fault or not in
order to not you know produce consistent
results
so that's that's that's the problem of
variance it
exists and you know it's it's a problem
that all of us
uh you know deep learning enthusiasts
are you know trying to solve
so these are also the problems that we i
talked about in the previous slide which
like we took care except for the
accuracy part
okay the second one serious lack of
reliability this stems from the first
problem itself if you're
a model or if your algorithm falters or
let's say
for succumbs or you know like false prey
to the problem of variance then of
course your model is not going to be
reliable enough in a real time scenario
which is again not a very favorable
circumstance
um third a lot of doctors have the
misconception especially what we got to
know when we started working on this
problem
that they are uh sort of reluctant to
you know use
these algorithms in in place of their uh
you know medical expertise so there was
like a
so they thought that it's like a
trade-off so one day probably this
algorithm is going to replace them in
the long run
but uh what we would like to again
highlight here is that was absolutely
and that is not
the motive at all and what we want to do
here is we want to propose an
enhanced form of diagnostic pedagogy
which will work in you know cohesiveness
so in like in in time
with the doctors that are there and it
will sort of you know
coalesce with the medical expertise
that's in play
already uh like the traditional way of
treating patients
and also use this algorithm to you know
detect various disease
which are you know probably solvable by
the means of computer vision
so we can move to the next uh i would
request my co-presenter to take on carry
forward with the presentation from here
uh
thank you deepam thank you for that
wonderful explanation as well
now talking about what like uh
as michael presented up till now talked
about
why we did what we did i would like to
throw some light upon
what did we actually do so now talking
about our
algorithm i would like you to take a
a little note of the fact that we're
using the test case one
or the octx uh problem that we first
you know discussed about where uh there
was a
there was a data set of ocd images
that were essentially used for uh you
know classifying different types of
retinal disorders
so now talking about our model this is a
workflow
of the model that we actually build up
so
now here as you can see what we did was
after the initial data acquisition
process
we then pre-processed the data by you
know means of different methods such as
data augmentation one that was very
important
in this test case scenario as well
because we face the problem of
you know class imbalance so now that was
one thing that we had to
uh sort of look after so after doing all
these initial steps what we did was
we took these three pre-trained models
which are like mentioned
uh in the workflow model in front of you
and
a custom cnn that we build ourselves and
we
individually train these uh you know
different data
different models and uh why did we
choose these model architectures that is
the question that's uh you know there's
a high chance of you thinking that right
now that why did we choose these
specific
uh you know pre-trained models only
uh when there are like there are
literally so many more of these you know
dozens more
dozens of these of different model
architectures already present so hold on
that
to that thought we'll be answering that
in a short while
so after you know initial training of
these models separately
what we did was you i am quite sure you
can see that
red circle right there that is our
initial or that is our main contribution
in the entire study
that is our ensemble uh you know model
that we came up with
which ensemble in the literal meaning of
the
uh word like that is that model actually
added up the
individual performances of these models
and gave us a
better model but you know outperformed
almost
all of these studies individually and as
you can see we later tested it on on
unseen examples in the validation step
now
moving on the you know the phase one
of this process was the training in the
inference space again we have taken our
first
uh test case into account as earlier you
know answering the question that i
earlier asked you to hold on to we use
these three
uh pre-defined or pre-trained model
architectures because of
you know one very important fact being
they were
actually compatible with each other so
when we're talking about
ensemble learning or uh you know
ensembling different kinds of
uh uh pre-trained architectures so that
one thing that we have to take into
account is the fact that
all these different models should
actually you know complement each other
and be compatible with
each other and actually increase the
efficiency of the entire model and that
is the reason we
took these models into consideration
besides the fact
of their individual performances being
uh you know
quite remarkable so other than that we
use the adam optimizer
uh after you know testing some of some
of um
you know some different optimizers such
as your rms prop
and we found the adam optimizer to be
the most suited for this
present study so that is why we chose
the different models and the optimizers
that we talked about
now here is a tabular representation of
the different
metrics used against the you know
different
pre-trained uh model architectures and
our custom cnn
for your better understanding of the
kind of individual performances that we
obtained
by training our uh you know models with
the
individual models with the uh data set
with the same data set if i may add now
the second phase the training and the
inference
phase two now here this is the
uh you know the red circle part of the
initial workflow that we talked about
the ensemble
model which we in this present study
named octs
so here as you can see we have you know
n number of deep neural networks that
were for in the case
uh you know in the case study that we
talked about earlier so
we are depending on their uh
performances
initialized or assigned uh non-linear
weights to them
after which we designed and trained our
ensemble model
freezing uh all layers except our fully
connected layer and the dense layer
post which we retrained the entire
ensemble model
after which we tested it on you know our
test set or the
you know unseen examples and found the
performance or the
result to be better than all of these
individual studies
now over to you deeper i would like you
to
throw some light upon our contributions
in detail
correct thank you so much that was a you
know very very brilliant explanation of
a very concise explanation of what we
have actually done here
um the how of it if i may um now
uh coming to the you know very objective
uh you know pinpointing of what we have
actually tried to achieve here
so number one it's sort of you know it's
called the dream of every
deep learning enthusiast to of attend
art accuracy
any research project would of course try
to attain more accuracy than all of its
previous studies and uh to be honest
when we started out with this project
that was not even our primary
our primary aim was to just combine
different neural networks and see what
happens
you know based on the experiments that
we conduct um this was a result
and why was this happening uh this is
very important
i believe so this happens because of a
very
important statistical theory which is
called central limit theorem
so central limit theorem essentially
talks about that
if you combine different you know models
or
architectures together your combined
model is supposed to yield you better
results better performance
in terms of a lot of aspects than all
the individuals
individual models you can come by uh it
also talks about
as a as a quality to that particular
principle uh
as a to that particular principle that
you cannot ever
you know breach the accuracy of uh you
know perfect
one or like 100 accuracy um but i don't
think that's like
a necessity as well uh in in order to
like
conduct a study essentially for research
purposes uh
second we talked about uh reliability
resiliency of course
the ability to take tackle the variance
problem and now why
does this problem get solved by the
model that we
you know generated by combining
different architectures together
okay it's very simple so when we have
different
architectures in the context now rather
than one single architectures used
multiple times
have to realize that these architectures
have very different characteristics as
well from each other
and when we put that into account when
we factor
that in we have to realize that the
disadvantage is too that each of these
architectures have
are sort of counteracted with the other
architectures which is exactly where my
co-presenter talked about compatibility
of models
and that has been you know one of the
more uh you know
essential things that we did take care
in this particular study because
like i said resiliency in my opinion is
more important than even accuracy uh
because
yeah in in real world you have so many
unseen examples and
they keep on coming every day that's
that's that's how it happens
so if your model is not you know
resilient enough if your model is
not resilient to changes to unseen
changes or unseen examples it hasn't
seen before
uh it's it's very problematic and in
order to tackle that very thing we
sort of tried to combine different
architectures together and move forward
with that and
it was able to solve the problem um
thirdly we
uh you know very fortunately enough
again this was an observation out of the
experiments we
have uh successfully mitigated the
chances of overfitting
um and we will my co-presenter will uh
you know like
visually show you by a graphical
representation how that happened
um but yeah so the overfitting problem
has also been taken care of
by this particular uh you know method
that we are
proposing here and i think that
is one of the more primary indicators of
the performance
and my co-presenter will take on forward
from the performance analysis to the
results and show you how it's done
thank you thank you for that uh
introduction
now coming back to the performance
analysis
here we can see the uh you know the
confusion matrix in front of us
and how uh we can see that the accuracy
that we got was nearly 89.5 percent
whereas
the misclassification that occurred was
close to
1.47 now that
is very important to uh you know as my
co-presenter earlier said this is a very
impor
important result or
a very important you know thing to take
into consideration that
actually proves that our study is uh
resilient
and is uh you know one that can be
over time we improved in we actually
applied for clinical
uh you know usage and clinical tests as
well
now moving forward the convergence and
the
convergence of train versus validation
loss function
and the accuracy curve again i will
uh come back to you and ask you to take
this forward
sure so um yeah like i like i was saying
uh so we actually tried to mitigate the
overfitting problem right and this is
the evidence of that this is the life
evidence of that so
uh like my co-presenter also mentioned
like uh
considering the test case of octx we
trained the final
model the the ensemble that you saw
for uh entirety of 250 bucks and these
are like some of the graphical results
that we obtained from the same
and as you can see like the training and
the validation loss curve sort of
converge
very beautifully um so that that that
was a very interesting observation to
note
also because yeah that that that sort of
you know tells you how your model does
not over fit
or are a little bit you know like
resilient to changes
that that occur during the training
process as well um
so that and um if you can move next
right now talking about the
representation of results here what we
did was to make this study more
uh you know inclusive for all uh the
our you know research fraternity and
uh make it more useful and actually
concrete for the medical
uh you know for the people of the
medical domain as well
what we did was we uh instead of going
with
just one kind of representation of our
results we actually took into
consideration
two different methods of representing
our results
and whatever it is that we uh you know
sort of uh
you know got because of the study that
we performed
now talking about the first kind of free
presentation the
grid representation here we can see that
the
misclassified images are labeled in red
and that actually you know in this
random batch uh
or random you know batch of samples we
can actually see the
few numbers of the misclassified images
which again
uh stands as a testimony to the
robustness or you know robustness
of our study now this particular
representation
uh comes in very handy for the people of
uh from the you know research community
or deep learning enthusiasts and
everybody who actually want to take away
of the results of our of study in an
easier way
now talking about the results
representation
you know predicted results
representations of test results with
confidence scores
now this method is very very important
for the
uh you know diagnosticians or the
medical practitioners because this
actually
helps them uh you know
get an understanding of the probability
of these confidence cause
and although you know basically the
probability of their diagnosis being
right in the case of you know
overlapping classes so
this is something that actually uh you
know proves to
aid them in uh trusting these
uh you know machine learning or deep
learning models and as we said
though in like as we discussed earlier
one of the problems that we faced was
the fact that we found the medical
fraternity to be kind of apprehensive
towards
accepting uh ai into uh
common or in the you know mainstream
healthcare so now
this is kind of a representation that
actually
uh aims towards bridging that gap
between the two communities now
here is an additional study the
comparative study between the landmark
data
between the landmark uh you know studies
uh
done on the same data set that we've
tabulated in front of you
here the first study that i would like
to talk about is the car money at
all study which is a very important
study
on this very uh you know topic of
classifying retinal disorders because
this is the study that actually
uh was the one behind fashioning the
data set that
have been like used by us as well now
coming to the rastoki at all study now
they actually used a detection system
based on deep learning models and
this study is the one that sort of
inspired us to come up uh you know take
up this specific problem in the first
place
uh after which uh we when like we met
with the problems that we discussed
earlier we came up with this idea of
ensemble xsf now the third study that
uh is mentioned in the table here is the
octx study or the study that
have been uh that has been uh authored
by
me and my co-presenter as well so as you
can also see in the uh you know in the
tabulary presentation our study
outperforms
uh these two landmark studies in all of
the three metrics later
now this is again a visual depiction of
the or
you know little insight into the papers
if you want to
uh you know read them or get to know
them in details so this is what you've
done here
now over to yuri pump to discuss about
the planning
enhancements and the scope of
improvements
thank you thank you so much um so
okay so now uh let's like finally talk
about
the enhancements or areas of improvement
that's that that we can work on
and that there is to work upon in this
area so the first one let's talk about
that uh
it's it's i think the most important one
among
all the three so of course there's no
thumb rule that exists in determining
the number of models that you can use to
ensemble different neural networks
versus
the amount of training data that you
have right so
we have done our for example what i mean
by that is so for the oct study
we have had used different data
augmentation techniques etc and we have
you know sort of you know managed to
increase our data
set data set to somewhat around let's
say 70 to 80 000 images perhaps
and we thought you know like that but
again there was no formula
which could tell us or or direct
relation or even an indirect relation
that
could tell us that you know for 80 000
training data you
might just use four or five models
there's nothing like that it's
completely empirical
based and simultaneously for like the
legend and study when we started skin
lessons
uh we had very few images around like 12
000 images
and we used two architectures there so
there's no
thumb rule there and you know i think it
will be really interesting in the future
if you can come up with something like
this i think it's going to be a
very important discovery in this
particular direction as well
um second of course faster computation
with less
or reasonable resources because there's
there's of course a trade-off
that that i'm sure like all of you
listening to this presentation would
already
have you know like that have crossed
your mind that
you know when you're increasing the
number of models you're increasing the
number of convolutions you're increasing
the number of complexities
uh naturally your resources or your
compute has to go up because
here you are not just training one model
but you are training you know n number
of models together
so that's that's that's definitely our
trade-off that exists but yeah we
will definitely you know but i
personally i don't think this is going
to be a problem given like the kind of
advances we are making in that's pure
of uh resources when it comes to gpu etc
uh and yeah lastly better optimization
of course who doesn't want better
optimization so as
as more you know optimize your models
are
more compatible your models are together
um
the better they are um and i think uh
you know like one of
the very uh you know important things to
mention here would be
uh you know how we can we can actually
you know like
you know try to develop a particular
system of combining these models
uh we have definitely you know proposed
a system here and i think that system
works
i truly believe but um we should also
realize that this system is also very
experimental based as
in you cannot possibly reach to the
correct number of correct
models at the very first go you have to
like go on go and go on and then
finally see that this is yielding you
the most best best results
and accordingly go with the same but if
we can actually
devise a mechanism to know that these
are the models that probably are very
very good together
uh that will be really nice but i also
somehow believe that these are a little
you know data data oriented as well uh
the learning capability
so can we move on to the next slide
um yeah so now uh uh one very important
thing that we
like to mention here about the
presentation in general is um
so i know this is probably not
you know like the same it would have
been had we
been there in person physically in pi
data global
and you know we would have talked and
interacted after our presentation
regarding all the
you know probably thoughts that you
would have or we would like to you know
like
no more to advance in this particular
direction but
we really you know would appreciate if
you write to us in our email ids and you
know
uh i know it's probably not the same if
if it would have happened over a cup of
coffee
um but yeah i we would really uh you
know we will of course meet you at the
q a panel session but i am uh so we
we saw when we when we sort of tried to
record like right now when we are trying
to record this presentation what we are
trying to do here is we
instead of like narrating the entire
presentation what we try to do is we
sort of try to um you know have these
preconceived
questions that you probably would have
trust in your mind
and try to answer those beforehand in in
order to make it a little more seamless
because of course we won't have as much
time
um so these are our email ids and um
uh if we can move on to the next slide
right uh thank you uh you know from
the both of us uh to the organizers
and the speakers and attendees and of
course like the
people of the community who strive to
make this uh community bigger and
brighter every day
and if my co-presenter has to my
co-president will present her water
of thanks right thank you uh first and
foremost thank you to my
uh co-presenter here for
not only this particular presentation
but
also the all the research that sort of
went behind it
it wouldn't have been possible without
you now
coming back to this uh prestigious
platform that actually
gave a chance to you know mirror
undergraduate students like us to
actually dream big and you know trust in
ourselves to
bring about the change that we want to
see so thank you for this
this lovely this great great opportunity
and uh thank you for all the organizers
we
can imagine the kind of work that goes
behind
uh making this conference so seamless
and you know what it is and
thank you to all the speakers and
attendees
again without uh people you know being
there and actually
being interested in and paying attention
to whatever you're representing or
saying
it sort of you know nullifies the point
of that so
again this wouldn't have been possible
without each and every single one of you
we
actually will look forward to hearing
from some of you
uh you know in our emails and we would
love to
connect with you through our emails and
again thank you from my end and my
co-presenters in
to making this lovely community bigger
brighter
and you know more wonderful everyday
thank you and we do look forward to pi
data global 2021 and
uh possibly in a you know physical
setting sure
that's that's there yeah true thank you